gentlemen congratulations on your work
in this movie
it's just it's beautiful and the
relationship between
sam and tosca is is so real it
it feels like people you know or people
that you've loved is that a direct
result of the fact that it's the two of
you doing this together that you have
a real-life friend relationship
off-camera
i think it will certainly be partly to
do that
um you know whatever that
brought to it and what however much
however helpful it was to
to to me and to stanley
it's really more to do with how it was
written you know
we really played the words that were on
the page and
i think that this was a an amazing feat
of restraint and good judgment by a
young writer
um who i think trusted to
well he trusted his actors he trusted
things that people often are afraid to
trust like silence
um like not not not going for the big
guns you know this is the film doesn't
rely on on fireworks at least not for a
long time and um
i think that stan and i
are now ancient veterans and it was a
it was such a wonderful relief to read a
script that
implied that and that offered that to us
you know i remember saying one of the
first conversations i had with stanley
was just
because we'd seen his first film harry
mcqueen's first film hinterland
which is also largely a road trip
i think this is this guy's going to let
us not talk
you know this is going to he's going to
allow this thing to breathe
and um so i think a lot of it is that i
think it's in harry as a writer harry is
a director
and yes the fact that stanley and i have
known each other for a long time and
we're not afraid of of those silences
and
uh you know we have that comfort with
each other
what is it like for you guys when you
get to see each other
work close up like colin you've got that
great monologue
at the at the dinner table like stanley
are you watching this guy
just going damn he's good like what's it
like for you
um yes that that is what it's like for
me um
it to watch colin is
it's one of the reasons i i asked colin
to do it i sent him the script because
he's just one of my favorite actors um
he's one of the best actors around and
to watch him
work was a great joy i admired watching
him work
um 20 years ago when we first worked
together
and then again 10 years ago but this was
very special because it was so intimate
and
it allowed us both to access
aspects of our friendship that the other
films didn't but to just watch him is
is a great honor and a great joy to
watch somebody who
knows what they're doing
[Music]
i know i have to reciprocate that of
course um why
i reciprocate i mean it's you know and
it's just it wasn't just because i like
stanley
you know um it's i i love the way he
works i love his work i think it's
mesmerizing
and uh i think when someone opposite you
is that good you feel you your own work
you can do it you get it for nothing a
lot of the time
yeah the the joy
of working together is clear but is
there going to be a joy as well if
you know come awards season you both get
to go on this ride together
if you both get recognized for your
performances
if if we you're saying will it be joyful
if we're both yeah like what will it
mean for you
you know due to your friendship and the
connection that you guys have
if you both nominated this award season
oh no i think the gloves will come off i
think we'll be furious
[Music]
it'll be a blood bath
i know that you uh you enjoy food and
drink in
in lockdown have you guys taken up any
new hobbies or worked on anything
interesting
well no i mean i wish i had i i
you know it's all been very deserting my
attempts to
make use of the time um uh
it's been largely funnily enough i i
used to play the piano a bit
and um neglected it over the years
and found out doing this film because i
i had to
be able to play something i
it rekindled um the design you know my
regret at having neglected it
and came back and so i if i probably if
i focused on any one thing that i
wouldn't normally be doing
it was going back to the piano
that's good yeah
with very very little results